okay [ __ ] okay [ __ ] it's your
voice like a babo oh [ __ ] how many use
this in a while um and we're back we're
back in spin it it's not a [ __ ] wall
I'll met that um but we are now starting
with the far harbor DLC I was gonna get
nucca world clearly I haven't waiting
this whole time clothes like I'm gonna
buy anything it's gonna be new crocs it
looks so dope and sure enough I go and
check up and it's a piece of [ __ ]
apparently that one says far harbor is
the good ones oh but I dad okay um where
the [ __ ] is my [ __ ] is my companion oh I
have a companion this is my communion
strong change my oh that's my companion
okay okay weirdo again we're doing good
um oh ok let's say here we're doing far
from home [ __ ] what that [ __ ] that
listen to Valentine's detective agency
radium it got a baby i got it setting
this to repeat this is Elli Perkins from
Valentine's detective agency with a
message for Nick's party office I'll be
waiting mercure birchen is to repeat
shut this [ __ ] annoying [ __ ] that
[ __ ] wading through the grass haha let
me take a look yeah what is that [ __ ] he
said what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
how we ship provisioners oh yeah my
problem okay detective ages hey why are
you betcha oh yeah ok I'm in setting
marquee let's do this [ __ ] let's do
this it's been a [ __ ] a while you
know what I'm saying Trump's been busy
tom has been busier than ever okay
baybay um he says central now ice water
that's a real yeah okay okay here we go
here we go arrogance me know yeah yeah
yeah I don't even remember my gum how
long yeah [ __ ] it we'll do it live well
they're alive I'm glad you're here we
got a new case while you and Nick were
out ready to put on the detective hat uh
yes sir let's hear a chump is a
fisherman who lives on the edge of the
Commonwealth Kenji nakano nakano huh
that name takes me back hmm i'm a proud
time your face is kind of [ __ ] up so
maybe if you bothered writing things
down Nick can't do that wouldn't want to
put you out of a job huh I'll remember
that the next time you need me to
consult hysterical client mr. nakano
didn't leave many details said he'd go
over everything when you need him yes
you baby how does any markings I test
that is in case guy had a worried look a
mile long I'm on it I'll go check it out
thanks Ellie the nakano residence is up
in the northeast near the coast a small
fishing house he said that he and his
wife will be waiting for you it's a long
walk that's how the hardcases always
stop in a
okay how [ __ ] far as this thing oh
[ __ ] that's far um okay you know what
the [ __ ] is that this is why you should
get your kids vaccinated look at that
[ __ ] that's disgusting okay yeah we're
God my god I'm betch fun where's that
[ __ ] is he still has a gun I you Kim it
gave him like a [ __ ] dope ass gun
okay remember though yeah James all
right I think he's a final judgment if I
it's a [ __ ] dope ass gattling gun you
know what I'm saying [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying I should really put on
some like visual upgrades of this [ __ ] I
getting close is that now like is that
this is Iraq why she like random gunfire
noises no ain't none of my business that
i always say i canta con out where's
your [ __ ] out what the [ __ ] where's this
guy live
[ __ ] is this [ __ ]
thank you hey
and now we going to the [ __ ] Sahara oh
great a [ __ ] farl goal bet you matter
i love betches buckets Mustang I let's
say this [ __ ] still got it oh [ __ ] oh
right rigorously very [ __ ] down I have
to say okay what I got to scale this
[ __ ] okay there's just been job here's
how that one that fetches tearing him up
sometimes like I do the job for us
hey you guys got any good oh shut i
don't make them like a tacky in pocket
he'll have once [ __ ] oh [ __ ] so much
coming
that [ __ ] that move it is it safe
what's that hey I'm list I don't think
we're alone get him there we go
del I takes her that's got to kill this
[ __ ]
yeah and I'll [ __ ] up over there let's
[ __ ] you kill thank God ok anyway we
gotta you gotta keep moving here ok here
and do how the [ __ ] I don't know we
[ __ ] scaling mountains in this game
ok dad God and God hours [ __ ] 'god oh
I'm always looking for an econo I don't
get it ok ok now there it is ask them oh
[ __ ] hey get that at the [ __ ] break
in my walls um dammit come in I know
you're listening on the other end boom
shakalaka my daughter that is [ __ ] up
you've been at this for hours she's out
there right shed Raiders well how do you
like [ __ ] grab oh yeah say they call
me the serial cat goner um you know I
don't work for free and that was my
price ok hello sorry I like oh sorry mr.
nakano
okay I hope you don't mind we let
ourselves in Nick thank God you need to
get to work right well I say hi to be
hurt she could be whoa slow down uh
Kenji was it why did you go over the
details with me and my partner here
brought a partner good the more eyes the
better yes yes yes sorry with neck
battery with you and Nick Nick didn't
tell me ran with him on one of his case
and you can hey this guy's I've I yes
boss he needed what is on his head he
scraped his [ __ ] ahead we would
double-cross nice ass once we had what
he was looking for I still have someone
lead lodged into my hip right hey Santa
cuz I don't ever come back to me sorry
things ended sawa yes that's all that
mattered and now you can maybe your
daughter's [ __ ] lack of their head is
discussed stank I let that yeah that's
me lowly partner I love the sarcastic
response it really shows that chump
doesn't go far right getting back to my
daughter yeah it all started with this
damn rate and I started saying how do
Kasumi likes to fix things the radio was
her latest project until she made
contact with son maybe it's cuz he named
her Kasumi and she ran baby she left on
her own she's not a child anymore our
daughter is 19 she knows less attractive
him dancing I think maybe she left
because she wanted her own life I'll
find out she would have told us where
she was going she would have said some
match I know my daughter is in danger I
can feel it hey I can feel me if you
want see now give me that money fat talk
money investigations for the mr. Trump's
always up my name sorry about this ng
expenses and all that of course how does
305 [ __ ] more than that batch Marvin
I went far that means travel expenses I
am NOT going to barter over my
daughter's life your fee is going to be
an i'll take it very hard
and I find her don't use ass thank you
her room is upstairs if that helps and
if you had any don't worry no I can't
jail get to the bottom of this ok I got
a question these betcha Olie mr. nakano
mr. scrape had about my daughter yes I
need some daytime see more you can tell
me about I don't know what more to say
she's my love girl she has an out
dangerous as the teacher and father Todd
are like technology tell me more I've
tried to get the damn thing I thought
you just wanted to strip it someone made
contact with that Jesus uh-huh okay and
I think we're now betch okay I gotta
investigate her [ __ ] around which
part gonna be disgusting with [ __ ]
dildos all over our place you know any
time to go to investigate her room Mitch
[ __ ] dildos all over the place [ __ ]
disgusting I got a question this mission
ice hello bad way Ian's about my
daughter ya see reasons i live in your
husband do we both want to find her
kenji still sees her swaddled in diapers
yeah bad chill out chill out she wasn't
sure yeah okay Adam mrs. nakano I can't
take her [ __ ] around look there's
someone in the chat room watching its
god that's good I'd take some notes but
I take some notes okay cuz i'm gonna
solve a [ __ ] murder I always say here
is I just bet she's a porn recording
what I can remember when I wake up I
keep having she's not gonna be needing
this anymore in a white room people are
talking about me like I'm not there or
maybe they just don't care are they it's
not [ __ ] care I don't know jolt like
a spark of electricity
to the back of my head and then everyone
turns to look at me god I hope I don't
have it again tonight [ __ ] you got like
some [ __ ] mental illness ok well
enough of that not for that uh what's
the current mission esta gate it well
where is the [ __ ] I gotta punch a
note tonight [ __ ] [ __ ] I got so much
[ __ ] ok I hear it I hear this all the
dreams I'll play this thing project flog
lamp yep lamp filament plus power equals
white hey I swear sometimes I think my
parents write these things just to keep
me dis hey all right this one project
flog radiation King television mom says
these things actually used to broadcast
you say in the dryer still around if you
head to the city of course she wasn't
too happy when I asked if we can make a
trip out there ok hn project log kitchen
mixer the circuits are still good but
all the mechanical parts are rusted
through maybe I can all right everyone
I'll be back in a few days was there
anything else alright this one um hello
crafting a project lot nothing but
Stefan sorry right there hey shout sign
but it is a [ __ ] fish hello sir hello
baby got here you're the [ __ ] out of me
okay that's out here all right [ __ ] out
here that [ __ ] so I can't laugh dead
want to [ __ ] live with this residence
I'm trying to get his house already all
right we're [ __ ] upstairs is there hey
Nick business couch over a bathroom we
would pick this out yet and that [ __ ]
is dead no wonder she left this place a
[ __ ] [ __ ] all there's a hole in the
ground okay oh wait it is it's a radio
project blog radio correction working
radio I'll finally get some nudes
outside this house my handle is going to
be let's go with Ohm's law that should
confuse the crisp and I cool if someone
actually gets the reference then will at
least have circuitry in common hey sure
she goes by Ohm's law this [ __ ] here
that's like necessary oh okay
look at it sink in chicken joy there
nothing in here okay I guess that's it i
was at a [ __ ] shake weight chitin
here did I really check the place out
this is only con is one of those
vibrators no joke okay nothing nothing
its shell shock and dad yeah well do you
want me to do okay [ __ ] am I looking for
all right yeah this is investigate the
house Thank pan yeah that's a [ __ ] get
[ __ ] angry yeah you know get my blood
pressure up let me just look at the log
data nice to get the nakano residence
[ __ ] investigating but I don't see
[ __ ] here yeah outside ago check is this
yes this is techne the residence is that
picture frame cigarettes maybe she was a
smoker you know as yours a smoker I got
a lot of advanced [ __ ] here that's for
sure belper and grandfathers know you're
it locked out s out of the safe what
answers you're in the boathouse picture
where the key is oh there's a [ __ ]
safe and the pictures over a year okay I
got the cake safe there is the [ __ ]
safe now here it is not the final
holotape project blog um myself I never
really thought about who work what I am
but God later I start the radio I was
right about the range I managed to get a
signal a strong signal from up north
there's a group of people up there they
say they're all sent some bettik people
made by the Institute they're trying to
build a place for their kind hey they
can be themselves and he accepted for
what they are alongside human beings hey
it sounds wonderful but then they
started asking about me and some
questions came up question I don't have
answers to I mean I've always felt
that's what I think like I'm not really
supposed to be here but then there are
things in my childhood I can't remember
and I've been having strange dreams I
I'm going to go to meet these since I
I have to know the truth about myself
they've told me to sail up north to a
town called the bar harbor I can make my
way to them from there so the daughter
takes off by boat and more importantly
there's a colony of sense up near this
far Harbor we need a way to get there
let's go talk to kenji hey water ken j
you've got a lot to answer for mr.
nakano have you finished your
investigation did you find anything
matching I need to ask you an important
question what kind of question uh-huh I
think I know work assume she went that
far up north god there's no time to
waste wait did you find out why she what
doesn't matter because I know my
daughter and if she didn't tell us which
you're right detective ever sent
daughter made contact what that she's
not a sin she's our daughter we race
uh-huh are you sure yes I know my
daughter this is what I was afraid ah
you have to get too far Harbor take my
ship on the dot right that's Hagen I'll
get to the buff thank you I know it'll
be hard waiting for word but try to
carry on
and I tell the railroad about that
though although railroad
I [ __ ] that [ __ ] Romer doesn't deserve
any of my business apology that's her
money that's got a pitch last cow
where's that where's the [ __ ] other
guy
there's what's-his-face holy [ __ ] that
he'd to leave me that I Lena okay
all right i mean
jet blocking out again too many drinks I
cut the Far Harbor all right I can't get
it again
that's my second disgusting
how could you come here
[ __ ] yeah welcome to far however okay
ok
a high pitched out for Harambee